what's goodie welcome back to hot breath
the show where you learn comedy from the
pros
that is my host guinness i am your
co-host comedian joel byers and our
mission at hot breath
is to help cultivate the next generation
of great comics and we are doing that in
this
type 5 series where we're helping you
create a tight five-minute set
ready for bookers so we have a few tips
for you here and a bonus one at the end
so be sure to hang out
and let's get to it so last episode it
was all about
the overall structure of a tight
five-minute set today
we're going to talk about the actual
minutiae the mechanics
of a five-minute set that's tight
and a few tips to actually help you
get those laughs permitted up and get
that set that's gonna get you
booked so first things first
tip number one in creating a tight five
minute set
is your word choice my friends now there
is
some common theme in comedy writing that
says the hard
consonants are funnier because they have
more impact they have more oomph like
instead of saying
uh money you say bucks is just one
example of money is a softer word that
hits versus
bucks that really hits you in the face
really has that impact really has that
punch
that you're looking for when you're
creating punch lines
get it get it guinness
okay we're running out of time but a
word choice exercise that a lot of
people don't talk about
is actually funny words and this is
something that i learned from watching
seinfeld
and he recently did a writing expose
i don't think that's the word i need it
was a funny word but i don't think it
was the right word so your funny words
need to be in context
i'll just play the clip what makes that
joke is you got
chimps dirt playing
and sticks and seven words four of them
are funny chimps chimps are funny
but you can see there that he this is
this guy's basically a billionaire and
he is still looking at the minutia and
the fine tunings of his joke that out of
those seven words
four or five are funny he cares that
much and your word choice is that
important a lot of your humor is going
to come in the economy of the expression
now when it comes to the economy of the
expression the next tip
is to understand your premise
what is the premise of your joke what is
the message of your joke what are you
trying to say
in this joke every joke should have a
premise it should have a baseline
of what is this joke about sum up this
joke in a single sentence or phrase
chris rock has said
that if people don't get your joke
it may be because they don't get your
premise so a way to really start to hone
and refine
all these wordy jokes that we have a
habit of creating is to ask yourself
okay what am i trying to say here what
is the premise
now what is the most efficient and funny
way
i can express that premise oh that was a
good tip
if you found that tip helpful go ahead
and hit that subscribe button
so more comments can find these tips all
right and the final tip
here my friends is to actually
transcribe your set and we talked about
this in
the last type 5 uh episode which if you
haven't heard it yet
go back check it out and you will learn
about how to actually structure
your five-minute set but when it comes
to transcribing your set
another helpful hint here is to actually
transcribe it
and then bold where all your punch lines
are
so now you can start to physically see
where all your punch lines are
so you can start to either get them
closer together or
if there's a big gap between them how
can you find new punch lines in between
these two punch lines
and it may come down to your word choice
it may come down to word economy where
you really start to ask yourself
are these words necessary and a bonus
tip
we have here is to actually
use your instincts is to actually
use your common conversational style
to refine your jokes so after you write
your joke
actually say the joke out loud practice
mark norman told us when we interviewed
him on our podcast
that he actually walks around his hotel
room just
talking out his jokes so they become
conversational
from start to finish i get an idea that
pops in my head
i jot down that idea then
i take it over into uh i do an hour of
writing every day about maybe an hour
and a half an hour
uh i take it into that and i just play
with it i just walk around my room and
just say it and
say this and that and this guy says it
that guy says it how
you know it's like clay you're kind of
like molding it and squishing it
which sounds incredibly pretentious but
you know you're just [ __ ] around with
it and then something funny happens and
then you write that down
and then something else funny happens
you write that down so eventually you
get like four or five funny lines then
you try it on stage
four out of the five lines don't work
but one does and you keep that one then
you try it again
so you can do the same to actually start
to refine your jokes so they come off a
bit more conversational
once you have your joke written okay now
say it out loud and are there little
tweaks and
little adjustments you can make to make
it sound more conversational and natural
and make it punch harder
so those are some quick tips for you to
create that tight five-minute set a few
editing tips if you will and this whole
series we're doing here
at hot breath is to help you create a
tight five-minute set ready for bookers
so if you want to carry on the
conversation connect with me and other
comics about this topic
join our free facebook group where we
are sharing even more content about how
you can level up your comedy and help
you get booked
i hope to see you there don't forget to
subscribe to this channel or subscribe
to this podcast if you're listening to
the podcast
version and we will see you on the other
side
bye say bye guinness
all right